J how has financing your earlier films
evolved into how you find money now has
it gotten easier is it still the same
animal it's just a different I don't
know I'm probably not explaining it
correctly but is it easier now or it's
just a different way it's still
difficult
I think financing is always difficult
you know whether you're raising the
money whether you're paying for it
yourself
that adds difficulties that are hard to
explain the pressures of that are
enormous whether it's going to a studio
and getting money if Stu gives you a lot
of money trust me you will feel it when
you're making that that film so I think
it's always hard and it's always a great
responsibility and it's something that I
just because my personality never take
lightly
so it's always like with me but that's
why I think it's just important to
whoever you're you're collaborating with
whether it's you know actors studio
people investors whatever it may be you
have to meet minds with them and feel
that connection so that everyone's on
the same page trying to make the same
thing and and that's I mean it's
interesting it's kind of a metaphor for
the theme of the movie is is like you
know creating family and and and
creating that special nest to to do to
do the bold and courageous things that
you want to do in your life did you
invest your own money with the puffy
chair and bag head yeah you do so you
showed you know people that you had your
own skin in the game yeah do you think
that's important for a lot of people cuz
so many people they say oh use other
people's money don't use your own but
don't you think in the beginning that's
probably the best way to prove that
you're willing to invest in yourself and
take a risk yeah it's I think it's I
think it's helpful to invest your own
money into whatever projects that you're
doing
you know that's something that I've
always done and that I believe in and I
would never be a part of a project that
I wouldn't be willing to invest in as
well
but I do think especially in the
beginning it green lights your projects
and it makes them go faster you know and
it allows you to explore and it gives
you the freedom to be yourself and to
take more chances you know so the more
because I think the most difficult thing
about making a piece of art is really
like figuring out what you're trying to
express and to do it in a truthful
manner and if you have a lot of voices
in the room before you really know who
you are it might be hard to figure that
out where does someone go to figure that
out that's interesting movie sets and
just be sort of in the background know
oh you got to do your own I mean I just
personally believe if you want to be a
film director you need to just be a film
director and there's no limitations all
you need is a 5d you know you don't even
need a 5d ya iPhone I guarantee you if
you make a really fascinating script and
shoot it on iPhone people will watch it
and your next film will be bigger you
know it's I think the problem is when
people come in expecting to make
Apocalypse Now on their first go you
know it's probably not going to happen
you know you need to start small and and
figure yourself out and allow yourself
the opportunity to mess up and do it
again if you mess up and also you said
know who you are you would only really
find that out and sort of the heat of
the moment behind the camera with ya
whether it's just two people in a park I
think there's something about our
culture that has us thinking that we can
figure out who we are inside of our
heads but that's not how it happens or
at least that's not how it happened for
me I think the way you figure self out
is by doing things and by being in
relation to other people and as a
filmmaker the way you figure yourself
out is by making things and failing or
succeeding and finishing the film and
showing it to strangers and seeing how
they react to it and how they feel about
it I think that's the only way to
to really figure out who you are and
what you have to offer because if not
it's just inside of your head it doesn't
doesn't really mean anything in the
greater context of the world but we all
want to just do it in our heads because
it's safer
you